ist wasser vielleicht der neue
treibstoff für raumschiffe ein
russisches start up unternehmen
jedenfalls will genau diese technologie
etablieren als drei mal so effizient wie
chemische triebwerke und als schlüssel
für die erforschung des sonnensystems
beschreiben die gründer ihre idee schon
2019 soll ein erstes test ins all
gebracht werden hammer
die infos links und science fiction hier
gibt's täglich faszinierende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen wasser gilt für viele
weltraum forscher und forscherinnen als
hochinteressante rohstoff weil es in
wasserstoff und sauerstoff aufgespalten
werden kann und klar ist sauerstoff ist
für uns menschen wichtig und wasserstoff
könnte als treibstoff dienen auf der
erde geht wasserstoff schon seit
längerer zeit als ein heißer kandidat
für eine emissionsfreie zukunft des
antriebes solch ein von wasserstoff
angetriebene elektromotor könnte vor
allem in verkehrsmitteln eingesetzt
werden in denen reine elektroantriebe
mit batterien nicht mehr klarkommt
beispielsweise bei schiffen flugzeugen
oder auch in lkw im rhein main gebiet
beispielsweise sollen diese lok schon
2022 durch personenzüge mit
wasserstoffantrieb ersetzt werden sie
werden emissionsfrei durch eine
brennstoffzelle angetrieben dort
reagiert sauerstoff wird wasserstoff und
strom wird erzeugt im gegensatz zu
batterien kann hier in minuten getankt
werden auch das russische startup
momentus hat in diesem bereich große
pläne
allerdings bezogen auf den weltraum
demnach sollen raumschiffs schon in
naher zukunft mit wasser angetrieben
werden allerdings ganz anders das wasser
selbst soll als reaktions masse in den
triebwerken als antrieb genutzt werden
hier soll durch stromzufuhr ein plasma
erzeugt werden also wasser würde stark
aufgeheizt werden dann aus einer düse
austreten und so den vortrieb erzeugen
das konzept trägt den namen thermisches
lichtbogen triebwerkes würde quasi wie
ein dauerhaft pfeifender teekessel oder
ein dampfkochtopf aus dem man überdruck
ablässt funktionieren heißer wasserdampf
erzeugt den rückstoß einfach aber genial
die vorteile der technik es wird sehr
schnell ein sehr großer schub erzeugt
weil das wasser eben extrem aufgeheizt
wird größer als millionen triebwerken
wie sie heute schon bei satelliten
eingesetzt werden aber nur relativ wenig
schub erzeugen
dennoch soll auch eine dauerhafte
nutzung gewährleistet werden umso
größere distanzen zurückzulegen zudem
ist wasser wesentlich preiswerter als
gase wie xenon der gründer des
unternehmens ist der russische
ingenieure und physiker michael kokorec
und er sieht seine idee als
zukunftsweisend mit dieser technologie
könnte endlich das gesamte sonnensystem
erforscht werden dieser antrieb könnte
beispielsweise objekte im sonnensystem
bringen und das im vergleich zu ionen
antrieb mit xenon gasen ihnen nur der
hälfte der zeit bis zu zehn tonnen
könnten so in die geostationäre umlauf
gebracht werden der erde so zumindest
die angaben des russischen startups der
treibstoff könnte direkt vor ort
abgebaut werden denn wasser ist an
vielen orten im sonnensystem zu finden
schon 2019 sondern erstes testgerät ins
all geschickt werden
dieser prototyp namens ziel benötigt nur
eine energiezufuhr von 30 watt und kann
allerdings nur relativ kurz zünden 180
sekunden aber das halt mit extrem hohem
druck dazu gibt es bereits einen vertrag
mit dem europäischen raketenstart
anbieter icm space der den prototypen
auf einem mikro satelliten befördern
wird der erfinder kokorec ist äußerst
optimistisch was seine lösung für das
antriebs problem angeht wenn die
transportkosten sinken entstehen viele
geschäftsmodelle
konkret denkt er an asteroiden bergbau
mondflüge und weltraumtourismus aber
natürlich könnten sie auch raumsonden
angetrieben werden die zur weiteren
erforschung des weltraums dienen ob
überhaupt und wenn dann wie gut dieser
theoretische ansatz tatsächlich in der
praxis funktioniert wird sich wohl auch
erst dann herausstellen wenn das system
wirklich erfolg hätte wäre dies durchaus
als absolut riesen fortschritt in der
raumfahrt und könnte uns die türen in
neue welten öffnen
wie es mit dem projekt weitergeht der
vater natürlich hier bei pixum abonniert
dafür am besten auch den englischen
kanal denn auch da gibt es immer wieder
videopremieren und darunter geht es
weiter mit new evolution aerospace
corporation ja auch die esa macht bei
antrieben extreme fortschritte ich freue
mich auf euch auf dem englischen kanal
stay tuned co2